let's answer some questions corejob has
one what potential playoff team
do you have the most concerns about
shireen i'll let you go first
well there's a couple in there i think
but mike i'm gonna go with seattle
seahawks because this is a team we were
talking about a few weeks ago
russell wilson's gonna win the mvp award
and this team looks like the best team
in the nfc
they don't look like that anymore and i
said all along even before this debacle
that they've had over the last few weeks
that you're not going to win a super
bowl with the 32nd ranked defense and
now they're 31st and i don't think
you're going to win a super bowl with
the 31st ranked defense and now russ
looks human you know let russ cook has
turned in to let russ burn your dinner
because that has not gone well over the
last few games
and i agree with you and there are
several teams about which to be
concerned look i think that the the
cream is rising as we get closer to the
end of the season the buccaneers out of
sight out of mind this week i worry
about them are they going to resolve
this strange power struggle between tom
brady and bruce sirians what's the
offense going to look like when they
play the vikings this weekend you know
the vikings have been
playing these strange close games and
playing down to the level of inferior
opposition they lost to the cowboys a
couple of weeks ago they really haven't
had an impressive win since upsetting
the packers at lambeau field if the
buccaneers don't have their act together
they could find themselves in trouble we
already are very concerned about the
cardinals who have fallen out currently
of the seven spots in the nfc there are
a lot of imperfect teams and look
december is when you either step up or
you step off and the teams that have
momentum now are the teams that are most
likely to win when we get to january and
i say this all the time around
thanksgiving every year there's a team
that's you know around five five or six
and six and they figure it out and they
carry that into january they become very
dangerous constrictor 14 what's more
likely the lions make the playoffs or
the steelers go 16-0 the steelers by the
way have just scored their first points
of the game a touchdown what's more
likely to you shireen
well i don't know that either is very
likely when you look at the lion's
schedule i don't see a lot of winds left
on there even with the daryl bevel bump
that they got yesterday and probably
will get maybe another time or two
this season but i
i don't think the steeders are going
undefeated either i guess i'm going to
go with the lions to make the playoffs
because they are right there what are
they one game out at this point so i'm
gonna go with the lions although i don't
give them a great chance to do that but
i do think the steelers are gonna lose a
game i mean they've got a tough game
what is it next week with the uh with
the bills and then they have versus indy
who i think is going to be very tough
and then at cleveland so those are three
really hard games and i think they lose
one of those games
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports